i'm will kane and tonight
as they say the rats are jumping off the
ship the lights have come on
and the roaches are scattering tonight
the lunatic fringe
that somehow has taken over the
mainstream left is running
from critical race theory you see for
weeks
cnn has ignored this
[Applause]
for weeks now msnbc implies this is fake
[Applause]
now the new york times would have you
believe this man has been duped by a
partisan astro turf
ginned up boogeyman and that his concern
isn't real
i don't have to be nice to you nobody
behind me has to be nice to you
if you don't like living in the united
states of america then you can all move
to russia
cuba or china this is the first
amendment
[Applause]
but that is very real because parents
are the tip of the spear the front line
warriors in this cultural revolution
they have seen little timmy bring home
how to bring home the book
how to be an anti-racist baby confess
his whiteness to mom and told his dad
that america
and he are white supremacists and
parents have had it jack
the lunatic racist left is starting to
lose
so as is always the case change the
rules of the game
obfuscate argue about definitions last
night on msnbc professional liar joy
reid
yelled at chris ruffo the man
responsible for exposing
much of the explosion of critical race
theory that he didn't really know what
he was talking about
let me respond at least once i haven't
gotten a full sentence because i'm i'm
not going to let you see one of the
things that i
don't know you probably never watched me
on tv just you know we didn't know who
each other were you know not too long
ago
but i don't allow people to just make up
and say lies on the show what i don't
think is right
is that forcing eight-year-olds in
cupertino california to deconstruct
their racial identities
sixty-four percent of americans now know
what critical race theory is no they
know what christians
you see she says critical race theory is
not intersectionality it's not whiteness
studies
it's not white fragility it's just stuff
taught in law school it's not a big
deal they tell us nobody is learning it
in k-12 you dummies
you're not really being taught racism by
your hr department
just listen to the first post-racial
president
you would think with all the public
policy debates that are taking place
right now
that you know the republican party would
uh be
engaged in a significant debate lo and
behold
the single most important issue to them
apparently right now is critical race
theory
yeah but from joy read to president
obama what you're hearing is the
fast-talking sidestepping stuttering
that comes at the end of a long con the
mark
independent non-trump voting mainstream
americans
who are finally waking up and playing
semantic games arguing over the
definition of the origination of
critical race theory sounds like nothing
more than
no see you don't understand what had
happened was what i meant to say
this is the definition of critical race
theory critical race theory is an
academic discipline that holds that the
united states is a nation founded on
white supremacy and oppression and that
these forces
are still at the root of our society
critical race theorists believe that
american institutions such as the
constitution and legal system preach
freedom and equality
but are mere camouflages for a naked
racial domination
now that's the definition from chris
ruffo who knows a thing or two
about this topic but whether or not
that's the working definition at yale
law
or it's the downstream language and
ideas that western math is racist
as told you by seattle public schools it
doesn't matter
i don't care we don't care we know the
values that lie
underneath these definitions these
definitions and they are racist
we hear it when hr departments play word
game associations where white men are
connected to
golf nascar and country music okay
some of those may be true but try
playing that game with another race and
see how it comes across
as racists we know it when you pass
bills in the name of equity that lower
testing requirements because what
black kids can't meet test standards
racist
and we see it when places like the
washington post ask us
to join white accountability groups
white people got to start getting
together specifically around race
wide accountability groups are really
helpful in terms of having a place to
process
having a group of people whose
responsibility
it is to call me on things or to
challenge me
most of us in doing this work have
experienced this where
there's a period of deep shame for being
white
and for acknowledging the harm that our
ancestors have caused
and that's a very legitimate piece of
this work
white only affinity groups that are a
lifelong project
what you mean like cinder sheldon
whitehouse's beach club like that kind
of thing
racist keep pushing people into their
racial affinity groups keep telling us
to identify with our race
and you know what will happen some white
people will actually take you up on that
and guess what
you'll have more real actual racists
but that's not the problem i'm told just
the other night on this program
i was told that individual racism and
bigotry that should not be our focus
systemic racism now that's the focus
that's what must be torn down
all critical race theory is saying as a
theory of law is
that it's not about individual acts of
bigotry or bias
or racism it is a systemic and
institutional network
that must be somehow discerned and
dismantled
must be dismantled so critical race
theory the legal doctrine
would tear down our laws and
constitution academics would tear down
the values
of western civilization hr departments
would tear down our identity
activists would tear down our history
pop stars
would tear down our flags and symbols
and
teachers would indoctrinate our children
i can't teach anything divisive i can't
teach critical race theory
and i can't teach about racial equity
after the show of last year we really
need to stand up and do what's right for
our kids right now so this is a call to
action teachers
we've got to stand up and fight for our
kids because this is
but i thought critical race 3 wasn't
being taught in k-12
i'm having a hard time keeping up with
that teacher here now
from iowa if you want to see real
systemic racism in play
real racism real unconstitutional legal
theory
look no further than joe biden's covet
19
restaurant revitalization program where
he prioritized money for restaurant
owners who
were black and preferences for
pakistanis
but not afghans japanese but not iraqis
hispanics but not middle easterners
that law was struck down by the sixth
circuit court of appeals of the united
states as
unconstitutional it's grotesquely openly
brazenly picking one race over another
and that is systemic racism the lunatic
left can pretend that critical race
theory is just classroom discussion of
race and racism as the new york times
called it
but parents know better they can play
word games and haggle over the
definition but we know racism no matter
what costume
it wears but as they run for the hills
and
run away from critical race theory
expect them to yell something familiar
back over their shoulder best
encapsulated in a tweet from
congresswoman rashida talib
who said opposition to critical race
theory is
obviously rooted in racism and has just
become the newest dog whistle
for racists of course hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else